[Music]
intro to systems
theory and cybernetics
yeah get us going i mean how much of a
dork do you have to actually be to have
clicked on a podcast about systems
theory and cybernetics
you must be bored it's pandemic times so
what else are you gonna do right
come to plastic pills i mean we're even
worse how how much of a dork do you have
to be to record
a podcast on systems theory oh god i
don't know if i would be doing any of
this if i wasn't trying to
incorporate it into my dissertation this
is your first
two-man uh podcast eric how does that
feel
i'm a little bit uh i'm a little bit on
edge i'm excited
i'm sweaty i'm nervous i'm having a beer
all these different emotions
i love the emotion of beer that's my
favorite state of consciousness today
it's a systems theory spit roast victor
and matt did some bonus episodes about
politics and rights
and boring [ __ ] like that so eric and i
felt that we had to one-up them
in the pill pod uh civil war
and we hope to accomplish that by making
a whole
series uh a weekly or bi-weekly
series yeah i was just saying
uh before that if we can be at least
as interesting if not more so than
victor and matt
then we will have done our jobs and
we'll still keep our
regular format of all of us coming
together for the the main
show but we're branching off a bit into
these uh micro doses and
two man pods yeah and if you
if you feel that we've accomplished that
goal feel free to remind matt and victor
on twitter
that'd be great yeah yeah um
speaking of bi-weekly i'm looking at
this word that i've written down and
does that mean
twice a week or every two weeks
because i meant the latter i would i
would understand it as maybe uh
once every other week bi-weekly it could
mean
twice a week biannual quarterly
quarterly means
four times a year not semi-weekly so the
the pill pod is always unscripted um it
will probably be forever unscripted
because that's the kind of chill
environment
we're looking for and the kind of
podcasts that i would listen to
if i weren't editing them all the time
however it doesn't mean we can't plan
and that's what this
is it's a planned series so the series
topic
as we've said is systems theory and
cybernetics which is a method
one that both eric and i endorse
actually it's better than marxism too
absolutely as we hope to prove yeah but
it might also be interesting
to explore perhaps ways that they could
work together
the old marxists with a new sort of
cybernetics point of view
there is things online like cyber
socialism and
cybernetic marxism i don't know much
about that yet but i got my eye on it
cybernetic marxism could work also
the cyber socialists are more about um
online
sharing of free access to knowledge and
information
data sharing kind of not not um
you know they'd be against the whole
like sort of structure of uh
of paywalling information in journals
like jstor and proquest and
academia one and all that [ __ ] that
would be
anti-cyber socialist that's
cyber capitalist i should say that the
cyber
prefix here is not the same
prefix as whatever cyber means when it
involves
cyber space or cyber socialism in the
sense that you brought up
the cyber in cybernetics comes from the
greek word kebernathau
and i don't know how to pronounce that
properly but it means
steersman yeah
the kubernete is the is the
verb and kubernetes
i think is the steers men and we know
that louise is going to correct us if
we're wrong about that so
yeah we got some we got some greek
studying patrons that'll
probably get on us up for our shitty
pronunciations we have
cyber that's all we need to get right
we're anglophones
the kubernetes gubernator stuff is uh
greek and latin
that's that's it's cool stuff but you
know
it's it's connected if you
speak of perhaps a gubernatorial
election it's the same route as
kubernau so when you call uh arnold
schwarzenegger the governator
back when he was that of california
you're actually pronouncing it kind of
close to the way it was in latin
before it got into english
as governor so systems theory
um and cybernetics in the sense that
we're using it are two things that i
never heard of
really until i heard of them
which is obviously tautological
but i never even heard people talk about
them in the way that
we talk about it until i encountered it
in an academic environment
or an upper-level academic environment i
should say
but eric's main area of study is
semiotics as well soon in part
though systems theory can be applied to
language and communication as
well as to consciousness
it was originally a biological concept
and then i think where our main area of
focus is probably going to end up is in
sociology so it
it's more of a method that crosses
disciplines
and if you're a fan of smashing words
together that's socio cybernetics which
is out there you can search it and
you'll find things
probably nicholas lumen but probably
other stuff as well
maybe some stafford beer with the
sociological approach
but that's name dropping i would go back
and
contest you know when you hear the word
cyber you can
totally think of things like cyberspace
and cyberpunk
and things like that because a it's cool
it's aesthetically it's the [ __ ]
you know cyberspace was coined by
william gibson who wrote
neuromancer which basically launched an
entire genre of literature
where the matrix also comes from this
idea right of the of
cyberspace and the matrix the machine
world right so i would
definitely endorse jumping to all of
these associations when you hear the
word cyber especially in literature
and art and movies and cool [ __ ] like
blade runner right that's like cyberpunk
i would bring all that in there because
it's machines it's computers
it's cyborgs cybernetic organisms like
this
is the [ __ ] when it comes to pop culture
but it can get very dry and we may stay
away from some of the more technical
points
that come out of cybernetics because it
was developed
by a group of mathematicians and
neuroscientists
whose general lingo goes way over my
[ __ ] head
but it is cool [ __ ] nevertheless and it
is trickled down to us
in various forms and sociology as we
said and
in philosophy and some of the stuff that
we do focus on
in our well your former phd in my
current phd
so yeah cyber i think it makes the jump
with the word
cyborg which as you said is short for
cybernetic
organism but as we wish to prove here
all organisms are cybernetic and that's
not in a
a hairaway sense either they're
according to the definition of
cybernetics in the technical way that
we're going to be using it
all organisms are cybernetic as well as
some machines
yeah i think i think uh haraway was kind
of
plugged into this but i actually went
through her book
today and i didn't really find any
references to the big
cybernetic thinkers so she's kind of
coming at cyborg from
maybe a bit of a different angle than
cybernetics she was trained in biology
so she must have known
about dundas someone we're going to be
talking about uh matarana
and varela who coined autopoises they
were biologists
who took a cybernetic approach to
biology
um but yeah generally yeah probably
heraway will
be left out of this story
and maybe you can breathe a sigh of
relief
um i don't know this but maybe you know
this i believe it's autopoiesis because
there's an extra
iota in there and i don't know if it's
the same word as
poesis as in poetics another thing that
we actually
should ask our patron um who speaks
greek
anyway this is a little bit getting
ahead of ourselves
so i'm not gonna lie it does get me
slightly hard
to think about cybernetics and heidegger
i i mean i have not gone there but
poesis autopoiesis
there's a connection there that would
really get me i pronounce it
poises but as i've mentioned before i do
not pronounce
any greek ancient or modern um anyway
listener what you have to look forward
to
here is uh we're gonna just do an intro
today
discuss what systems theory is in
general what uh cybernetics is they're
not exactly the same thing by the way
they overlap but we hold this view
the two of us versus our other two
compatriots on the pill pod
who are more into i guess liberal
humanism
or liberal socialism um
and that really doesn't the two are at
loggerheads they
are you can't really maintain both
systems at once
so maybe we'll have to bring our
information that we find here and go
back and
challenge them with it yeah you can find
the
social democrats i think they're i think
they're self-described social democrats
but they're coming from political theory
so we'll have to do a little bit of work
i think to
bring cybernetics to politics so we may
be at a slight disadvantage
comparing there's no there's no
cybernetic party out there yet maybe
there will be soon who knows the
the cyborg socialists i don't know
but unfortunately no i don't think
political science has picked up on this
not in the mainstream although you can
use
systems theory to describe political
systems for example how
uh in principle
a country that has open elections always
seems to
channel into basically a two-party
system
very often um sometimes there's a third
but
yeah and and it's really helpful to know
about the distinctions between the
the judicial and the legislative and the
executive branches of government because
i think
that if you're into cybernetics you
would make that distinction too
and call those sort of separate systems
that exhibit a kind of
what we're going to describe as
organizational closure
right so i think people are probably
confused because we've just mentioned
pretty much every discipline of
sociology and biology
and the reason for that is that systems
theory is a method rather than
like a school so you can take the method
and apply it to
any systems that's why it's called
systems theory sometimes
general systems theory and the
generality of systems theories that can
be applied to any system that reproduces
the conditions for its own
continuation through time yes
and cybernetics is is interdisciplinary
which is why we're all over the place a
little bit it is the
anti-disciplinary in some ways it was
born
in interdisciplinarity in and it's its
name
came around in the end of the 1940s
right with
norbert weiner's book 1948
called cybernetics or
the study of control and communication
in the animal
and the machine so it was born in this
interdisciplinary
environment and it
kind of encompasses a lot of different
let's say it does encompass a load of
disciplines but it is
sort of anti transdisciplinary maybe
though all those words just mean that
it's not
rooted in any single discipline it's not
english it's not history it's not
philosophy but it is all those things
right it's closely associated to uh
theories of
consciousness in some cases information
theory
was especially important at the
beginning if we're
talking about uh claude shannon or
weaver
this kind of information theory that
studies how information
can be measured early compsci von
neumann
was involved with the development of
systems theory's thinking or system
system theory
thinking so we're going to lay the
groundwork here
kind of discuss what we're going to
discuss uh
biweekly and those
episodes will be on the patreon if
you're interested in this stuff
um maybe not all depending on our
release
schedule uh but this will be in addition
to our
regular free content yes
yes sir so buy us a beer because we put
a lot of research hours into this
yeah preferably craft beer
canadian craft also we don't want no no
anheuser-busch
crap all right so with that said
i mean we're going organically i have
some point form notes in front of me so
if this sounds all good to you
oh one thing i did want to mention to
you you're not you're usually not the
culprit of this but we have a general
rule on the pillpot that is no name
dropping and no concept dropping
without explaining it um so you i
although you're not the culprit i just
wanted to reinstate that rule because
this is something
that i'm sure some people are hearing
for the first time
it's not widely used yeah
don't worry i've already caught myself
doing that i've already dropped too many
names
we're gonna need like six episodes now
just to explain
those names but we could name drop
uh plato since he's kind of the one
where the term first appears
so hopefully everybody knows that plato
plato used it
actually he used it to refer to
government
efficient government right because you
remember that cybernetics
refers to steersman like someone who
would steer
a boat they would be at the back of the
boat they would have their their rudder
or whatever
and the sea would be crashing against
the boat
and they would like lock their eyes on
their target right like they're
they're going across the mediterranean
they don't have compasses
this this isn't the modern this isn't
modern navigation
the guy's just sort of trying to keep
the boat steady
and pointed towards where he wants to go
and
the boat goes along the goal is to reach
the destination
and he's controlling the system he
doesn't have control of the system so
don't confuse this idea of control
with like sort of maybe an image of
of like nazis or any kind of coercive
control this is a control
in the regulative sense where there are
forces
crashing against your metaphorical boat
which your boat could be your machine
your boat could be your animal your boat
could be your mind
or whatever you want and the control
mechanism
the the steersman is trying to keep it
sort of steady
and on course and the steersman really
doesn't have complete control
it's a it's a regulative system right
it's a
that's the magic word it's a system
that's being controlled by
some sort of we'll call it a feedback
loop eventually but for now we can just
call it a sort of
controlling the ship the paradigmatic
example of
a cybernetic machine that everybody
uh has or knows about presumably
where is it in your house i guess
are they they're not they're not in the
boiler room but that's where they
that's where they're connected to i
guess right the furnace room
um and that's your thermostat did i say
thermostat or did you just already know
what i was talking about
i i had a i knew that i know that that's
the
the the archetype example of a of a
cybernetic machine is a thermostat
all right so when we're talking about
cybernetic machine what a thermostat
does is have a little
uh temperature thingy thermometer inside
of it
when the air around it is
cooler than the temperature you've set
it to then
it turns on your furnace and your
basement
until the temperature through feedback
uh makes this thermometer i don't they
used to have these old like little ball
bearings inside the thermometers i'm
sure now they're all digital
but as soon as the temperature reaches a
certain point
the whatever you set it to um
mine's at 23 degrees celsius and no i
don't know what that is in fahrenheit
but then it turns off the furnace until
the temperature
drops again then it will automatically
turn on and your thermostat does this
all day long
automatically and it's self
regulating so you don't need to sit
there and you know
throw more coal into the fire because
it's
automatically governed you might say
so that would be the sense of a governor
yeah and the more the more general term
you might encounter for a thermostat
would be like
a homeostat a cybernetic machine is a
homeostat
meaning it likes to stay at a stable
state so if you set your temperature you
set the cutoff at like say you want to
keep it at 23.
so if the if your temperature goes up
above 23 it shuts the furnace off
there's a mechanism in there that turns
it off
and then presuming you're you have the
heat on because it's cold outside your
the temperature will cool down and once
it drops below a certain
point it'll flip back on again
and then that way it maintains a sort of
homeostasis
you'd call it like a stable steady state
think again of your your boat going
along the along the river the the ocean
the mediterranean sea the greek steering
and
a wave knocks them off course so the
steersman
being the the thermostat of the boat you
know this metaphor has to correct
the course of the boat and and by
probably moving the rudder a little
further than he had it before and then
the boat corrects and he moves the
rudder back to the middle again
and where all the uh all the soldiers
are happy on their way to
rape and pillage the ionian coast or
wherever they're going
right right and the whole idea about
this uh
about a cybernetic mechanism is that it
auto-corrects
you don't need to infer something like
conscious thought and to
explain a thermostat all of this happens
automatically
and you can see where the connection to
biology is why don't we just jump into
that
first because this is where we broach
systems theory
you have a lot of these systems in your
body
for example you
get hungry you get hungry you don't have
to consciously think about what that
means
that means you go need to go scrounge
for food
use grounds for food your body tells you
you're full and
that you can stop eating that would be a
cybernetic
mechanism inside a larger system
yeah yeah i can i can also embarrass
myself by not knowing what that thing
those things in your ear
called when when you're off that they
help you maintain balance like because
when you have an ear infection it's
really hard to balance
so it's like your your balancing
mechanism and your ears are off
i don't even know if these are good
examples anyway i was going to say when
i get too drunk my brain just shuts off
because it's like all right that's
enough alcohol and then
you pass out right i don't i don't know
if that's a good maybe that's a good
example
i mean organisms are extremely complex
right like if you want to try and
model like a single celled organism that
is like
even a really really complicated i don't
even think we have enough computer data
to model
like a couple hours of what a cell can
do never mind
like an entire human being so on the
like mathematical precision side
organisms you just
can't deal with them in any precise ways
but
yeah these these complex organisms like
humans
and dogs and cats and all kinds of
animals like
they are they are also cybernetic they
just
have three billion years of evolution
behind them
whereas most of our machines are only
one or two hundred years old i guess
stafford beer says the first cybernetic
machine was probably like a watts
engine yeah so this is not what a system
is by the way this these are kind of
mechanisms but they go into
describing systems more generally so
systems more generally are used uh by
systems theorists
very specifically to mean a certain
number of things and not
certain other things and a very
important part of this
is what we're calling this auto
correction they need to be able to
correct by
changing the environment which excludes
certain things from being systems of
course
so rocks are not systems
animals are the solar system is not
a system because it doesn't change its
environment
in order to you know perpetuate itself
whereas uh human language is a system
mm-hmm yeah and so the the sort of
i guess i guess you could say systems
thinking is a is a
maybe um i don't know would you call it
maybe a paradigm
i mean in in this in this sort of
article i read to prepare by andrew
pickering
uh he points out that cybernetics is
almost like a paradigm shift like when
we're saying paradigm shift
like think like thomas kuhn paradigm
shift or
well he describes it but galileo does it
right he
shifts the paradigm and now we're
shifting the paradigm again
into this cybernetic systems theoretic
paradigm it's it's kind of a new way of
looking at the world so instead of
focusing on correctly representing
things
like newtonian science is a
representational system right you
you just get it get the get it right get
the descriptions right get the
mathematical descriptions right and you
have a perfect mirror
of nature in your in your textbooks or
wherever
whereas with this it's more engaged
right you're you're
doing things in the world you're looking
at the world
as active as
i don't know if this is a word agential
filled with agency
agentic i think but and it's important
to note that
agency obviously preceded systems theory
but it was always thought of as being
connected to consciousness or
human beings specifically or god i guess
um but this shifts shifts the emphasis
to
i guess the automatic action
of non-human actors
yeah and uh and i was also going to say
um when you think of systems
as well i mean you wouldn't be totally
wrong to go
back to german idealism and think of the
systematic philosophers
and they're the sorts of ways they start
looking at things like especially hegel
right who we've done episodes on already
we didn't focus on him from this angle
but
you could you could talk about him as a
systems builder he tries to build a
system and fit everything into that
system
right where everything is interconnected
everything is related
everything is based on instead of like
positivist descriptions of what's out
there in the world
it's based on distinctions within the
system
right so you start at a certain point
like sort of with everything and nothing
at the same time
which is where he starts in the logic
book with being in nothing
and then you make that that initial
distinction
and that's when a system sort of comes
into being a system
is distinguished from its background and
so
you wouldn't be wrong to think about the
system's philosophers in the in this
german tradition
but it certainly takes on a new
life in the middle of the 20th century
which is where
like the story of cybernetics properly
begins i guess you could say
yeah and when you're talking about a
system one of the defining features of
it in this
context is that a system is preparing
itself to receive
new information from the environment and
this could be
as you just mentioned eric sort of an
idea might be an example of new
information
so when you talk about system building
philosophy what they're trying to do
is be able to anticipate what new kinds
of information
might become that their system has to
take
account of and it's a little bit of a
loose example but you can
think more directly about uh your body
for example your body receives
information from the environment
in the form of heat say
and when your body gets hot it has a
automatic mechanism to deal with that
which is that you
sweat so you sweat the water evaporates
this cools off your skin
and then you stop sweating when you
return to the word you mentioned earlier
which is homeostasis
yeah you could think of the heat of the
environment
as the input your body as the sort of
system
and sweat as the output in that in that
sort of
like because the input output model was
sort of where it all began i mean this
story gets a little complicated when we
get to
auto poises and i don't know if we'll be
able to do it justice because there's
some pretty um
there's some pretty subtle [ __ ] going on
with these guys but yeah the input
output model
and the machine learning sort of model
is
kind of where it all started like i
would i would also give the example
that norbert weiner who we've already
mentioned who
coins this term and and gives this whole
way of thinking its name
cybernetics uh he was
i mean this is gonna give it all a very
horrible military feeling
and it's not that but he was working on
a
um an automatic uh air gun right a gun
that will shoot down planes
and so in this sense you need something
called called
feedback so information being fed back
into the system so for instance you'd
have a
a gun connected to a servo mechanism
and you'd have a radar system that
tracks a plane
and as the plane moves the radar feeds
the information
into the machine the machine and its
algorithms right it processes that
information
in order to make predictions about where
the plane will be in a couple seconds it
takes 12 seconds for instance for
a shell to reach a plane in the sky so
they will
uh it will move the servo mechanism and
it's an anti-aircraft predictor gun
right and this is this is the idea i
think for norbert weiner where this
whole approach was born so you
you need that constant feed of
information into the system where the
plane is
so if the plane changes direction the
radar picks that up
the feedback mechanism which feeds the
information back into the algorithms of
the system
will then make new predictions and
correct the guns position and
that's sort of ongoing so so if the
plane went off the radar
you know the gun wouldn't be receiving
any more information it wouldn't know
where to shoot it would
it would just stop moving so that's
that's another that's just another
example lots of examples they help
anyway i wanted to get back
a little bit onto track of what we're
talking about in terms of systems
communication as you've heard is very
important
and the reason that systems theory can
be applied to something
like i mean we have an election come
earth not we
there is a very large global election
coming up um and this you could use it
to describe a political system
in which the goal of the system
is to maintain itself it's actually to
prevent change
and or at least large changes and
every system is trying to keep change as
incremental as possible and to respond
to what might be system
damaging events that occur to it and
this is kind of where we
cross over into things like the legal
system which is based on precedence
or um computer systems
and the way that the and the way the
online communication functions so really
they're about adaptation is one of the
one of the biggest
or most accessible words we could use to
describe this so
um whether it's an economic system
whether it's a biological system whether
it's your own body
these things want to continue and they
want
to adapt to changes so that they can
continue
yeah that's right yeah yeah the goal to
um you could also say yeah their goal is
to
exist their goal is to
perpetuate their own existence
especially when it comes to organisms
right like
their goal is to you know keep existing
and eventually reproduce and
pass on the genes to a new generation
and so living systems are very much but
also social systems legal systems
even your psyche right your brain is a
is a psychological system that's
connected to
other systems around it your body your
nervous system
all the other systems of the body and
their goal is to
yeah either you could say maintain
themselves
stay the same or you know stay in
existence
to perpetuate yeah i'd like to make the
transition to
post-humanism also because it tends to
be a post-human area of
research um and the reasons for that
actually i'll kick it to you to explain
that in a second one thing that we
haven't yet mentioned but it's very
important to
systems theory that includes cybernetics
in this case but
systems theory is about observation so
for a systems theorist it depends very
much on where
you're drawing the lines of a system
that you're observing
which is called second order observation
i think we could do an entire
hour on just second order observation
but this means
that the system is where you
as the observer draw the lines for it so
just as you could draw a line around an
individual cell
and say this is the one cell that we are
now talking about you could just as
easily draw a circle around the entire
organism
and say okay now we're talking about an
organism and you can go further up
say no we're talking about a species and
a species
ability to evolve and adapt and if they
don't adapt of course
they go extinct or if things happen in
their environment too quickly
they go extinct or you could talk about
life itself as a system
so really what you're looking at or what
you what you get out of observing the
type of communication that's observed
that's occurring really depends on where
you as the theorist
are drawing the line around the system
so the position of the observer
becomes extremely important in uh
in systems theory yeah and and this is
really when i said that cybernetics
represents
a paradigm shift well this is actually
now that we've brought this up we can
even be even more specific
is that the real paradigm shift does
happen when we start talking about
observers right because when i talked
about the classical newtonian model
right the observer in that model is
outside the system right they're not
part of the system
like this is how even this view persists
in the sciences today
if you go into a sort of science course
and yeah of course you're taught
newtonian mechanics and then you're
thrown in that sort of einsteinian
wrench into the whole system
but really like all your observations
are fine at
a sort of medium level so when we talk
about the transition to second order
cybernetics which gets going in the in
probably by the end of the 50s soon
after
we're talking about the observer as
being part of the system that is being
observed right like you've heard that
you've you've probably heard that saying
where you can't observe something
without changing it
um what's that called there's actually a
term for that from anthropology
but it's also in in quantum mechanics as
well you cannot
observe a quantum state you can't
measure a quantum state without actually
like
affecting that quantum state right so
the the observer
and by extension the tools that the
observer uses to measure
the state of the system that they're
interested in whether it's psychological
or
material or social they are
considered to be a part of that system
to be not
separated from it because before right
it's that view from nowhere
it's that it's that god trick this is
where haraway comes back in because she
coins this it's the god trick where you
remove your subjectivity
and you're just a pure objective
observing being your god
basically observing the system from the
outside
the second order observation you you do
have to include your own position in the
uh schematic you could say yeah
and this is getting us to the big kicker
the big point
um and that is the observer is
in systems theory not a human
or not necessarily a human it's not
conscious
or not necessarily conscious uh systems
observe
each other variously even even cells
bumping into each other or exchanging
fluids
is a type of communication that could be
called
observation because they're making
decisions about their
environment so the big
the big reveal here uh about 40 minutes
through
is that this is a post-human
uh system and we're not talking ab
from the view of systems theory there's
no need for
um even giving giving intention
or agency or the will
of of a person priority over
any other type of will over automatic
wills you could say
so uh one of the main systems theorists
that we're probably going to be talking
about
is nicholas lumen who's a german
sociologist
and for him there is no such thing as
humans humans are
multiple three in fact three overlapping
systems that we kind of confuse as
one thing because they happen to walk
around
as one thing but your body is only one
system the other systems there are
communication and the psyche
but this is where systems theory
branches into
a lot of philosophy that probably we're
familiar with
uh de luz for example there's a lot of
systems theory notions
in delisian philosophy and i want to
kick it back to one of the guys that you
know really well eric
is uh bateson who deliz and qatari
read extensively and bateson is one of
the original crew
of systems theory thinkers yes he he was
he was one of the main forces behind
this shift to the sort of second order
systems theory by
applying cybernetic thinking to the mind
to consciousness
to this idea you might have heard of of
of the um what we call it like uh
extended cognition
uh the way that the way that thought
isn't just
localized in the brain but it
takes place in an embodied system
and say that a mind is
a an extension
of the brain but
you know just to um drop some duluz on
you
as a treat uh deluse gets the idea of
plateaus
from bateson which is like um
how does he say it it's a it's a um
i actually have the quote right here
yeah gregory bateson uses the word
plateau
to designate something special a
continuous
self-vibrating region of intensities
whose development avoids any orientation
towards a culmination point or external
end so when you're reading a thousand
plateaus you can thank bateson for that
concept of the plateau
although the lose does things to it
to losing gothary have their way with it
as they do with concepts
but yeah plateaus and the embodied
extended minds sort of come from maybe
cybernetics and bateson i don't know
maybe you'd agree with that
i don't know and because i don't know i
will not comment on it before exploring
it further but
if you've if you've been tracking i
don't actually know how well we've been
doing this until i
listen to it back which is to observe
the system at a second order
but systems are processes
so this fits in with uh process
philosophy which
we discussed before and
they try to perpetuate themselves
in time by adaptation now we're going to
get into a whole bunch of specific
terminology
but one of the more difficult things to
grasp
about this is that systems
do not directly interact any system
by definition is a closed system
meaning that it draws a distinction
between itself
and its environment so
this is going to be counterintuitive and
we'll probably do an episode on it but
your language and
your mind do not ever directly interact
they are separate systems and they kind
of bump into each other
in what's called a structural coupling
but they don't actually ever
interact directly in that they don't
affect each other's processes
which sounds counterintuitive but i'm
kind of giving you the highlights of uh
of of what's interesting in here and new
ways of thinking paradigm shifts
so this idea of closure is um
so so when we will i'll just focus on
on nicholas lumen so nicholas lumen
reads these two biologists these two
chilean biologists named maturana and
varela
alberto maturana and francisco varela
and they write a book called autopilesis
and cognition the realization of the
living where they make a distinction
between organization and structure
and the idea is that systems are
organizationally closed but they can be
what you would say sort of causally open
so again going back to the brain the
brain is organizationally closed
it uses its own sort of
it it has its own i don't know what
you'd call it like a material
it has its own sort of it has it it has
it has its closed communicational loops
within it and it's closed off from the
outside world it's a
unity as you'd say but but structurally
it is open like it's causally open
so the fact that if you cut somebody's
head off their brain will stop
working it's it's open to causes
that are coming in from the outside but
in terms of its functioning
and it's its understanding of itself and
it's making distinctions between itself
like it's referring to itself what we
call auto referential
and it's referring to something outside
of itself it's sort of other reference
that all comes from the organizational
closure aspect
so that's really really important to say
so structural coupling
is the idea that the structure in which
the organization is embodied
the organization is sort of this is this
relational
structure you could think of it whereas
the the structure
structure part is the concrete structure
and that's open
in a way that it's well you just said it
it's structurally coupled to other
systems around it
so what you would call perturbations
it will receive perturbations from the
quote unquote
outside and it will then
um well what would you say it
compensates
within itself it it compensates for
those perturbations by
again drawing further distinctions you
know the
the again going back to the thermostat
right the thermostat isn't directly
seeing the temperature
of your house it's structurally coupled
in ways that make it sensitive to the
temperature in your house but what we
would call that is a perturbation when
it cools down or heats up too much
it perturbs the system and the system
then compensates
for those perturbances but
organizationally
it is closed you don't directly observe
the outside world you can only really
observe yourself and make distinctions
between your inside
and what's outside of you you can only
make those distinctions from within
this sort of organizational closure so
it's a difficult sort of
non-intuitive concept but this is where
lumen gets it from is maturana and
varela making this distinction between
organization and structure so you have
organizational closure
but you have a kind of causal openness
expressed by the term
structural coupling and perturbations
right the system itself is closed
but then it gets you use perturbation
which is interesting because i always
use the word irritant
but they mean exactly the same thing of
course
but there's a reason that you can't see
if you were to shine a light on your
brain
right because you need the eye the eye
is the kind of machine that is
structurally coupled to your brain
also a machine these are the delos words
for it of course
um or system but this
the purpose of the eye is to convert
information which are you know photons
that hit
the back your eye and then that convert
converts those into the electrical
signals
i don't know how this works by the way
but it converts it into electrical
signals
which is a language that your brain
understands your brain doesn't
understand
light but the eye can convert the light
into
uh the electric [ __ ] that your brain
uh understands yeah yeah so this is why
for instance like
psychologists can't directly observe the
contents of anybody's mind
right because the mind is a sort of it's
a closed unity
you can't directly observe it you have
to come up with strategies
you have to again come up with
strategies to experiment
and perturb and test and this is why we
learn
so much from things like brain damage
where we learn about lost functions we
learn negatively almost we learn like if
somebody has
a condition called aphasia because they
are
their brain is damaged on a certain part
either
broca's area or wernicke's area or
whatever you get this type of aphasia
and then we know what aphasia is based
on what that person can no longer
do maybe they can no longer string
sentences together properly or they can
no longer
sort of speak like you get this kind of
aphasia so we learn things negatively
in that sense because as cybernetics
says you can't really
you can't directly observe the contents
of another system
you're you structurally couple with that
system in certain ways so
yeah that caches out in neurology and
psychology as being like you have to do
experiments
on the subject you have to you know ask
them questions and get them to
exhibit behaviors you have to elicit
reactions right when
you're in a psychoanalyst office that's
a perfect example of both second order
observation
and a system and the system that you're
trying to observe but you can't
is the mind but
because you as the psychoanalyst
understand language you can use your
language
to bring back the analyzands language
so to speak bring it back to your mind
and then
process that as information that your
mind understands so there's basically
three closed systems here
the mind under observation the language
being passed between them
and then the observer in this case the
therapist's mind and as
an observer in this case this is a
direct example of
a system that you can't observe without
it being affected
because necessarily when you're speaking
to somebody you're affecting their
their mind but the idea is that
they're operationally closed and you're
again just with the light example your
brain has to convert
um these sounds into something that
makes sense
and lumen uses the same word as his
surreal for this actually
sin is that right how do you pronounce
sin
just yeah scene scene it's it's like
meaning right or sense
s-i-n-n german but it gives you that's
what gives you the cohe
the cohesive picture which is a form
of closure and to observe yeah you can't
observe someone else's mind unless you
keep
talking to them and keep irritating it
or perturbing it
and that's how you get information about
a system that is
closed yeah and so this is kind of the
reason why
like like the way that that what i was
saying before that kind of view from
nowhere type of science
where they want to make like a model of
the mind like it's never gonna happen
because you can't represent which is
probably just another way of saying like
observe in the first order sense you
can't represent
another system directly through whatever
you want computer modeling right you'll
never get a computer model
of a mind because you can't directly
observe a mind
you can only observe it through these
perturbations as we were saying
so when i say like something is
organizationally closed
and i say it has its own sort of
material that it operates on it operates
on itself in a way in order to process
differences and so for
for a for like a political system for
example its material
is is power and legitimacy for a social
system
its material again in quotes is
communications
and you could say the same thing like
the psychological system
and the material biological system right
they're all
each interlocking they're they're inter
they're connected
and each of them deals with a different
type of information too right so
um the political system dealing with
power is is kind of an observation but
they make distinctions about what power
means power is this and not that
a good example would be the legal system
also because the legal system
makes distinctions between what is legal
and
non-legal and it's not like you just
write the law and now
you know what's legal and non-legal
that's what the whole court system is
for
and this is a system in the system sense
trying to determine
which types of input which types of
cases
cases would be its information which are
legal and which are
non-legal so that it's making
distinctions to continue
existing yeah so that's that's a great
point for a a social cybernetics
perspective right is that the legal
system
and the economic system and the
political system
there are all sorts of separate systems
they don't touch each other they don't
have
they don't have anything to do with each
other in the cybernetic sense
like you like like each system has that
organizational closure right
economics operates on money right
legal systems operate on on
right like legitimizing certain laws
right so so they can intervene in one
another
obviously but that usually creates
problems
rather than than solutions right like if
one system starts operating
to an excess and generating problems for
other systems
then you need then you have to look at
well what's going on say in the economy
because it's affecting
these other systems but they don't that
like from a from a theoretical
standpoint they they exhibit that
organizational closure just the same
right
that's what like lumens going to take
that out and j of
of maturana varela he's going to get rid
of the sort of biological reductionism
going on there because they're only
really talking about
their biologists so obviously and he's
going to try to apply them to different
kinds of social
systems so again the same principle of
of
of self-organization self-reference
closure all of these system all of these
things are going to apply and it makes
nicholas lumens sort of theory
really very interesting and i always say
it's an interesting alternative to
someone like
habermas or even bruno latorre or even
foucault who all have their own sorts of
social theories lumens really stands out
and being influenced by
systems theory in a certain way and
lumen gained his early
notoriety as a critic of habermas
actually
and then haberma said that lumen had
this like technocratic
functionalism that undermined the
possibility of
like an emancipatory politics
but if you see this from lumens
perspective like
i mean the crude marxist or neo-marxist
critique is like
power is money in capitalism
um and the problem is is that's like not
true
there's two separate systems one is the
exchange of currency
and one is the exchange of power so in
order to get from one to the other
it's not just that you have money and
then you also have
power at the same time right you have to
go out
and deploy that money in a certain way
by for example
donating to a gubernatorial campaign or
something like that so that exchange
is the structural coupling between the
two systems but it's very focused on
what are we observing at any given time
and this is
an example of two structural couplings
which are very close
but habermas didn't like that lumen like
made this
into his all of his writing basically
because there's not
really room for a free or
an emancipatory humanist ethics
in here uh because for for for lumen
ethics is just hopeless in dealing with
the complexity
of of post-industrial society like what
you what you want to believe to be true
doesn't matter at all and what lumen was
much more concerned with was how do we
observe
this in its full glory
but when you're when you are observing
as a theorist when
when we are doing theory then you always
have to create a simplified
model of the thing that you're observing
um and that's the another point that has
to do with this second order
is that you can never there's nothing
more complicated than the system
itself any representation of that is
always going to be
oversimplified but he was very focused
on
like don't say money is power because it
isn't there's an exchange happening
there and there's not like two essences
that are just
uh fundamentally connected or something
like that
yeah yeah and even in the way people
sort of caricature
foucault as as repeating that
that old bacon dictum of knowledge is
power well no
no knowledge is knowledge is a function
of of different systems right of science
and institutions and academic systems
right whereas power is
more associated with legal and political
systems so you can't really say one is
the other
that would be reductive and i don't even
think foucault actually says that
in in that caricatured way but i would
definitely
if when looking forward to some kind of
debate
between this kind of perspective and
perhaps the more um democratic
socialist perspective that uh that matt
and uh victor
propound i would definitely mine lumens
critiques
of habermas and especially um
habermas's theory of communicative
action
which really sort of turns on
generating some kind of consensus before
action can take place
uh i would definitely sort of lumen
dismisses consensus
as an important aspect i would say of
of action in a society i think i think
he has a whole different sort of
way of looking at it and i would
definitely mind that a little bit
if we're gonna we're gonna load up our
guns and come to that debate if
if and when it happens oh it's gotta
happen
that was what our our patrons voted that
was the second most
highest voted was us to have a debate
over these lines i think
um and yeah like just to just to
simplify
like blumen's criticism is like
something like
consensus is just too difficult when
you're dealing with the complexities of
highly differentiated societies um
because you know consensus consensus
about what about
money well that's all like that's one
whole area that you would have to
endlessly
under you have to understand it properly
before you could institute anything
um and then power is a completely
different system that you have to
understand and then
you know something as benal as
um who who needs to own cars in a
post-industrial society
all of these things are going to factor
in to the point where you can't just say
well if we agree on what we believe then
that will make our beliefs
take or establish themselves as changes
in the world
lumen's world is very difficult to
change and i think
the world is very difficult to change so
hoping for something like revolution
like revolution
is is so difficult and
almost never happens and you know
systems theory is good at explaining
that
and the the the quick definition here
that a
wyatt revolution is so difficult to make
happen
is because every single system is trying
to perpetuate itself
to not revolt and this means that
they're adjusting
they're like taking note of the
conditions around them unconsciously of
course but they're taking note of the
conditions
and trying to adjust those conditions so
that
they can't they can't be overthrown in
that kind of way
yeah yeah and there's definitely a
contradiction between the way
lumen sees the social system working and
and uh habermas's sort of theory of
rational communicative action is that
yeah like
if if a consensus ever really actually
happened in a social system the system
would stop working it would just be done
it would be finished yeah that would be
it because it's not
it that like the system thrives on
well there's a there's a distinction
here to be made because there's there's
this
legacy of marxism where there's
contradictions
within a capitalist system and they need
to be overcome
and for them overcome is really just
sweeping it under the rug
because those contradictions those
conflicts
are almost what the system is generating
as
part of its own activity right like a
distinction
what's another way to talk about a
distinction where you divide one thing
into
into one thing and another into another
right then they're in
conflict with one another they're
contradictory in a certain
sense of the word and so the legacy of
marxism that habermas sort of
takes up and waters down quite a bit
with his own
theories is that is that we need to get
over these conflicts and contradictions
and reach a consensus
in order to act whereas yeah lumen would
just say that that no that's just
skirting the issue
because that's not how social systems
actually work yeah and we're
to be fair we're bastardizing habermas a
lot by saying that but an example a
real world example is uh the latin
language because latin was tried
or was attempted to be purged of like
um local dialects they wanted to make it
basically the holy
the holy religion of christianity this
this ecclesiastical
latin and in the process completed it
but killed it because as soon as you're
finished as soon as you say we're
like this is this is what now latin is
and you don't permit it
to adapt anymore then
uh no one's gonna use it because the
world is always changing it's always
receiving new information and like
technically that's not exactly what
happened like latin evolved into all of
the romance languages but ecclesiastical
latin is not spoken
uh because they tried to perfect it
basically yeah it's a dead language
right yeah
and i just even maybe another like
pedestrian point would be that
that yeah all those differences right
systems are difference generating
machines
and so all those differences between the
local dialects
are what sort of make the system work
that's the
that's the material on which the system
sort of operates and generates and feeds
back into itself
so you need those differences right this
this view of difference
as being information like this is what
this is the famous line from gregory
bateson right information is a
difference that makes a difference
when you reach a consensus it's almost
like a difference now you have a
difference that doesn't make a
difference because everyone agrees
that's a that's a sort of very general
way to put it
to create differences is what's
necessary
for any type of you know evolution
every any type of growth and what
does evolution or what does evolving are
our systems rocks don't evolve
the solar system doesn't evolve but
species evolve languages evolve
economies evolve so evolution is a very
important part of
uh what makes a system a system yeah
yeah and it's a it's a view of like the
the the dynamic
nature of of you know the material world
like the non-human world it's a view
that this
it's dynamic it also generates its own
differences
so it's not this sort of static world
where
humans are the agents and everything
else is this
dead stuff that we operate on that's
that's again kind of going back to the
the scientific view but
i mean in in certain way like habermas
doesn't get away from that completely or
at least not to lumens satisfaction
anyway
that would be like a whole episode just
to describe that sort of thing but
yeah you need the difference that makes
a difference that's an important
sort of line in cybernetics differences
make a difference for some observer
like uh and the observer is again going
to be another auto
poetic system making observations
drawing distinctions and creating
differences in its own system in order
to compensate
for the distinctions it draws or it
thinks it's drawing right there's
there's always the chance that you
misinterpret something
right that's that's another fun thing
about communication
is that the chance for miscommunication
is is
always there it's never going to go away
and so
consensus is kind of an ideal an
ideal speaking situation where everyone
reaches a consensus we all agree
deliberative democracy works and life is
better for everyone
well i mean that doesn't seem to be
happening
it's a nice theory and not to say that
habermas is a is a bad
thinker he's one of the best but we're
we're taking sides here so
we're going to we're going to [ __ ] on
him a little bit we're going to take
swings
yeah and because you know matt loves
abramos quite a bit so [ __ ] that guy
and theory is a a rendering of the world
that's another
important thing like theory is not a
knowledge of the world
it's a verge a vision of a world
so to speak so that's why there's always
a capacity for growth because the
world's always changing so you can never
have a totalized system and i guess we
could reference kant here because unlike
someone like kant systems theory turns
away from the knowing
subject like the conscious subject
to reality that's consisted of these
multiple self-referential systems
and they are all observing each other
there's not like a special
observer which is something that we are
you opened up with here because the
observations of systems theory
are situated in the world
that they're also interested in they're
made of the same stuff
so uh yeah i've been reading a lot of
delays lately we have this concept of
university
and systems theory does not it
appears to break with that university
because it makes representations of the
things that it's talking about
like you and i eric are creating a
version of a legal system here
just by speaking about it that may or
may not correspond to the real
legal system we're creating a rendering
for it in the minds
of our listeners here but then the
content question of how can a subject
have objective knowledge
is just gone and then the question is
how can you
organize this complexity because you're
never going to have full knowledge it's
impossible you're in the world and your
knowledge is in the world
that is always changing
yeah and i think from a cybernetic point
of view that that
kant's uh thing in itself would almost
be
is is like the way kant sort of tries to
bring in outside the outside world
into the system like to sort of account
for it in his philosophical
system but it just becomes a kind of
black hole
it's it's the thing in itself you can
never know the thing in itself
so once we get to hegel
and then modern systems theory right we
get rid of that thing in itself and we
accept the fact that there's a kind of
organizational closure
and that's the perspective of the um of
the observer
and we don't need to talk about a thing
in itself in this sense like
kant almost like made a mistake and
discovered something great when he talks
about a thing in itself
yeah but the thing yeah with the thing
in itself it does exist
but it only exists inside kant's system
it doesn't necessarily exist outside of
it so
the what makes its reality and reality
is what resists
right that's all reality can be
something that resists
right like everyone like want they want
to get rid of it in the
wrong way like they want to get rid of
it in the way
like say structuralism and
post-modernism want to get rid of it
by just talking about concepts paired
with linguistic signifiers right they
want to get rid of the outside
world completely well we don't want to
do that but we also don't want a thing
in itself
right so we say you know the thing in
itself is reality it's what resists it's
the thing you got to go out
and you just got to do things and if
they don't work
then that's that's the that's the
resistance there and if they do work
well that's you sort of
overcoming the resistance and in that
process you draw another distinction
or you you know you map you you draw out
the recipe for doing that thing
you draw out the algorithm and you can
do it again in the future and you create
new differences that are going to come
back to
affect your observations later yeah like
we're never going to get we're never
going to pull the veil up on the thing
in itself we're never going to sneak up
on it from behind
as hegel says or step outside of
ourselves in order to see it
but it's it's just simply what yeah what
resists it's the source of why
we adopt an experimental model when it
comes to science is because you got to
go out there and you gotta test
nature and you gotta poke and prod it or
if you wanna take um
again going back to bacon in this
horrible horrible
sexist sort of language saying like
nature
is a woman you gotta torture her to get
her secrets well i mean
the the the way he said it is wrong but
the meaning is kind of correct i guess
and the reason that systems theory is
the best
one is because you can also have a
systems theory of systems theory
like there's not levels of reality here
there's not like a division between mind
and body
um because systems theory is itself
developing a system
and it simulates complexity as its
explanation
so it doesn't suffer from that problem
of
not understanding its own self
referentiality which is
often the problem that philosophy
uh falls into uh systems theory is the
object and the observer of social
systems both at the same time
so there's a self-referential circle in
there
right and unlike a lot of what i've
talked about before
in terms of uh semiotics and maybe
maybe i don't know if you'll agree with
this or not because you know that a lot
better than i do but
systems theory is looking for a general
direction of differentiation that's not
concerned with
language specifically as the one
example of self-referentiality for
systems theory every system is
self-referential
in a different way not just language
language doesn't create a whole new
well it does actually language creates a
whole new world
um but it's part or it's connected with
the world that it's responding to and
that's why it changes over time
but law does the same thing right law is
not like
uh a divine gift of god that never
changes law
to be functional has to change with
every
case um and the same thing goes for your
body
yeah like like yeah language is a little
difficult like in lumens system for
social systems like language is
communication really
and like communication isn't just
linguistic it can be non-verbal
there's all kinds of different
communications like what with semiotics
or what i would call
semiology does is it takes linguistics
as
the exemplary system on which all other
systems are moderate right
and almost in a way all the other
systems become embedded
so then like you get this sort of
linguistic turn
where you have this like language
creates reality point of view and like
okay that's that's a little bit right
but we're not
sort of all the way there because now
we've just taken out external reality
and like other kinds of communication
that are non-linguistic
and and i think i think the lose sort of
sees this
too because we spoke about lumens
division of of the
the psychic the biological and the
social well like
deluse kind of has that same sort of
division he has those three clusters of
strata he talks about in his geo
philosophy which is
which is the the material strata
where you know the the crystalline
strata and the geograph
the geological strata and then you have
the next one the organic strata
where you have the biological stuff
happening right you have genes you have
folding
you have all that stuff then you have
the third one which is the sort of
the human tool using language using what
he calls alloplastic
strata which is the third so you have
that you again you have this
three-way division deluge takes it up if
you read later gutari
and his three ecologies what do you get
there you get the material the mental
and the environmental
or the material the mental and the
social you get you get all those
that sort of again these three
interlocking overlapping but
ultimately organizationally closed
strata which are actually clusters of
strata so there's other systems going on
in there too like within the social
system you have
you have institutions you have
interactions you have all these other
sorts of
sub systems as i would call them
uh yeah and we and i i don't mean to
downplay the importance of language
because language is
one of the most special systems that
there is
and that's because it can it's so
flexible
like we could just invent a word here
whereas we couldn't invent
like i don't know an elementary particle
here
but because we can just invent a word
here and there kind of as we see
fit and then submit it to the the group
to be used or not used
it is the most flexible of all systems
because of how much it can represent
and that's kind of one of the sources
for
humans capacity to predict control
manage even into the future
control manage and predict and why we
are so good at creating our own
environment is because we have such a
flexible system at our disposal
which is language and specifically
written language
that you can store all of this knowledge
um
as its own system but when you're
speaking you're affecting
language you're not affecting the
world in a meaningful way
yeah i'd say that too because yeah like
this
language is is is still what
distinguishes
sort of humans from from everything else
but i think this is another way to
appreciate how unique it is
it's it's a more realistic way it puts
it in its place i think a little bit
better in the in the grand scheme of
things
than than a language-centric kind of
philosophy
right like like bees communicate of
course
with pheromones and whatever but you
can't represent
galaxies and pheromones right you need
you need a highly complex language to be
able to talk about something like a
galaxy
yeah and like language you can still use
symbols to
connect to arbitrary meanings which is a
powerful sort of tool that language
offers
but when you take that a little bit too
far it just kind of becomes like
everything is
everything is arbitrary when you take
that perspective like all of our values
all of our
scientific concepts are all just
arbitrary
sorts of words mapped onto subjective
concepts right like like you can you can
go too far
in that direction i mean they are
arbitrary but
they work still and that's kind of the
the point of systems theories why does
all this stuff
work when it's not strictly speaking
representative
and that's kind of what it explains i
think
yeah i'd say so like laws
work you can't deny that they don't work
but it doesn't mean that law
is like a perfect observation and this
is why we would have debates
about law um on the other on the
pillpot generally yeah like i guess if
laws weren't working
you would see some kind of runaway
feedback right like
when you when we talk about feedback you
know you have those two types
so when i describe the gun for example
like if the gun start
if the plane turns and the gun is no
longer pointing at it you need a
negative feedback loop to reduce
the um the sort of stimulation in the
system
you bring it back to a normal state and
then the opposite is positive feedback
like what we're doing to the environment
right now by putting all this
carbon out into the atmosphere what
we're doing is we're creating
positive feedback where we're taking a
system that was
operating in relative stability i.e the
carbon cycle
and we're introducing positive feedback
loops into it and we're going to create
this sort of that's how you talk about
runaway climate change that's what
people are talking about when they're
saying we're reaching tipping points
as we're creating runaway positive
feedback loops
so you can sort of see when like laws
and things aren't working
when they are sort of diverging away
from a steady state you could say the
same thing about
the economy too probably that the
capitalist economy creates these
positive feedback loops by
sort of making money the center of
everything like they want to impose
money onto
law and they want to impose money into
politics so you get things like
you get things like um like i don't know
unlimited campaign donations for example
like that could be an example of one
system
sort of perturbing another system to
such a degree that it creates
these runaway feedback loops and
eventually
you know what happens when feedback
builds up in a system too much it's no
longer a unity it can no longer
reproduce the conditions that it
wants in order to function normally it's
going to
dissolve in a way it's going to die in
biological language
yeah so like capitalism is
killing our political system in a
certain way or
you know facebook is is irritating
our democratic nicely working
political system by introducing all of
this information that's creating all of
this sort of
instability right we're no longer
operating at a steady
stable state yeah we got i mean just to
summarize what you said
positive feedback says oh i got some now
i want more
and negative feedback says okay i have
this
this pang or this warning so then i need
to return to
equilibrium or homeostasis or a normal
state so imagine if you were eating
and every time you took a bite you got
more hungry like eventually
it wouldn't take very long and your
stomach would explode
um so that's kind of what we're yeah
when you're talking about
either environmental change or
capitalism or any time you see
like exponential growth there's probably
some sort of
uh positive feedback happening and the
only thing that can end
positive feedback is a crash usually
killing
the system in question or at least
damaging it heavily in some way
for a long time yeah even going back to
our little steersman
guy right if a wave hits the boat and
knocks it off course right the
the steersman has to introduce negative
feedback to uh
steady the ship once more and get it
back on course because the course
staying on course would be the would be
the metaphor here for a stable system
and so any waves or any kind of
interference would create would create a
uh
something that you need to correct
through a negative introducing negative
feedback yeah when a wave hits the boat
you don't just keep steering the ship in
the opposite direction you steer it back
the opposite the other way which is why
it's called negative feedback
as opposed to positive feedback
anyway so uh eric if we do this for a
couple weeks
what other topics do you think will come
up i'm thinking like
compsci um we could talk about social
media
in terms of like an information managing
system because
that that seems to produce positive
feedback anything else you can think of
as
application or thinkers you want to
discuss
we've mentioned a lot of them but
there's a lot to go
yeah i mean i feel like we sort of just
scratched over a lot of the surface of
what's going on in cybernetics and
systems theory and and yeah and then now
we can
sort of zoom in a little more maybe
get a little closer to some of the
thinkers in the tradition if if people
are interested in
say like gregory bateson or nicholas
lumen we can get a little closer to them
but we can also look at things like yeah
like politics
social media i'd like to talk about
attention specifically because i think
um we have these we have a stable
homeostatic
system in our mammalian brain
but then the amount of information that
you're exposed to
now almost becomes overwhelming and when
it when your brain breaks
it turns into stuff like anxiety
disorder
maybe um there's there's links there but
you can give an
entire systems theory analytic over top
of
those connections and say okay we have
an explanatory
mechanism here it doesn't mean that the
explanation's always right
we can do experiments and i think i
think that'd be fun we could look at
marxism as a from a
systems theory perspective what parts of
it would work and what parts of it
wouldn't work because if you're talking
about
any sort of utopianism which by the way
i wouldn't
align with marxism without a whole bunch
of qualifiers but you couldn't have a
classless society if it wouldn't
if it wasn't going to encounter new
forms of difference that it would have
to adjust to because systems
need an environment where difference
comes from in order to feed them
so there's a lot of stuff we could talk
about i think we'll probably start with
feedback and autopoiesis which is
how do systems encounter information
and then incorporate them as differences
inside them
and we'll use plenty of examples i think
we can pick up a few books
what do you think yeah yeah i think the
the biological sort of approach is a
good place to start
and then build from there how do we look
at auto policies and
quote non-living systems i mean lumen
makes the the
just this beautiful simple argument of
like well if
if autopoiesis is only for living
systems well clearly like
social systems and psychological systems
have to
have to have life too right if there was
no life there would be no society
if there's no life there'd be no mind to
speak of
yeah it's so we could start at the sort
of biological level as well and work our
way out from there yeah if you want to
have a have like a philosophical
tradition
um touchstone i think like for me
the closest is like whitehead because
for whitehead yeah processing an organic
philosophy
means that everything is in process
which is the same observation the
systems theory makes
because it observes everything society
law people bodies all as
processes and the observation you know
takes precedence
over trying to define what something is
or structure
what something is you have to look at
how something is
which i think is is for me the most
interesting part of
philosophy yeah i wonder if there's not
something interesting uh with marx and
his view of labor
and sort of man in nature kind of view
of labor as transforming nature
and there's some great there's some
great parallels there between
the way that humans transform the world
through their labor
and the way that organisms operate by
sort of
you know transforming their environment
to be more like them
in a certain way and to be more um you
know conducive to further
to further auto poetic operations
and get a little more into those dirty
concepts of organization and structure
and autopoiesis and like
dig into that like what the heck is that
it's really a theory of unity right like
how can something
change over time but also maintain its
identity
right yeah coherence have an identity
like this is what this is what descartes
was thinking about in the meditations he
was like
he was like if i light this candle and
then close my eyes
and i open them a minute later and look
at it well how do i know it's the same
thing right it's
it's smell has changed its taste has
changed it's
feel it has changed everything has
changed about it so how can i
how can it maintain its identity through
time and of course descartes answer has
more to do with
well concepts ideas and being a thinking
thing
his his dualism is his answer to it but
we got another answer
yeah so some of those things would be
interesting to bring
into play and of course our podcast is a
system
as well that expends energy
and if you want to uh to come on this
little
conceptual journey with us i'm tired of
all the of
all the politics stuff that's why we're
that's why we're going out of the
politics to
abstract observation but if you want to
join us on this journey and you're not
yet a patron
become a patron today and if you don't
want to do that
then you can enjoy the rest of our free
content that comes out
pretty much every week yeah and the the
wolves
are definitely hungry for deluse so we
can also look at how the way to lose
engages with systems theory he's
definitely into systems biologists
jacques monod and other figures
jacob looks cool there's some
interesting relations between
yeah you could kind of think of
difference in repetition as a sort of
uh development of a systems theory
thinking it wouldn't be
systems theory proper because it's a
metaphysical but you know it creates a
coherence like that whole machine
ontology they have that's what you kind
of call it is like a machine ontology
machinic
being yeah like that that really kind of
comes into play with matran and varela
too living machines
they treat us they treat living
organisms like a different kind of
machine
rather than something ontologically sort
of
distinct yep that'll be hot hype
so uh we're gonna keep going with this
we would
uh love it if you decided to come with
us
if not then we hope you got an
interesting look at systems theory and
maybe you want to do some of your own
research we've been referencing uh
nicholas lumen a lot he's the main
thinker for sociological systems theory
then matsurina and varela of course
are the biological systems theorists
usually where the term is first applied
and then cybernetics
uh we mentioned norbert weiner and a few
other things
so yeah yeah i love it i love it
and maybe we can get to my uh my good
old cyber semiotics too
where this all sort of comes together in
biosemiotics as well you know i mean
soren breyer's book
if you haven't heard of him i'd look him
up but we should uh
we should definitely get to that in some
future
world because i love swimming yeah i
love hearing you talk about that stuff
and i don't know anything about it so
if we continue our our our little series
here then i would love to uh
i guess interview you about to ask you
questions about cyber semiotics
biosemiotics and all that
fun stuff yeah perhaps when we talk
about dairyda
a little bit or maybe we already did i
don't know when you're hearing this
maybe we did already but there's going
to be all right
or is an episode on dairy that will i
will where i will go off on semiology a
little bit
all right thanks eric thanks listener uh
we hope this was fun
we'll catch you later bye for now
plastic pills
oh yeah
[Music]
soundbite
you